how are you Steve yeah one of these days
I'm gonna have to tell you the story how
Andy and Reed and I met in a hotel in
our underwear but that's what that'll
live for another cage that lives for the
[Music]
Green Bay Packers in 92 and we we kind
of show up at the same time and to go
house hunting or our wives were there at
the Midway Motor Lodge it's really a
great place over there and and so the
middle of the night I don't know he's
here he doesn't know I'm here but we're
both kind of coincidentally there to
look for housing anyway the fire alarm
goes off and you know how you hear a
fire alarm
I shouldn't be kidding about it because
there's fires up here in the Bay Area
big time in Napa right now my god anyway
the fire alarm goes off and I go I'm not
getting up it's got to be a fake and so
and then it keeps going and going going
up oh my geez maybe there's a fire I
don't know so finally I get up I stick
my head out the door
I'm just looking for people evacuating
and I and I hear nothing so I looked
down the hallway and here's his big red
head coming out of another door and he
looks at me and I look at him the fire
alarms going off and he goes are you
cheating Reed oh yeah are you doing my
underwear on he had his underwear on and
we went and met in the hallway as the
fire alarms going on in Midway Motor
Lodge and go what are you doing I'm
gonna go with Krause congratulations hey
you want to meet my wife anyway so you
wrapped up with the cover of the sheet
or something I and we went out of the
hallway that's where we met Norway I am
mandated to ask a follow-up question to
which I may not really even want to know
the answer but boxers or briefs Steve we
got so yeah
best friends for life that's how you
become BFFs right there so but you would
know better than most it appears to me
Steve like he is just coaching with no
care in the world that he's just like
letting it flee steam it high and
letting it fly and it's been fun to
watch him you they where did it come
from this game last night and and and
you know they get some points and
everything but John Dorsey and Andy Reed
John's not there anymore don't know why
but they put together a team that's got
great team speed okay
that's what that must have been written
on their wall when they're when they're
trying to acquire and draft players
draft speed because they have it at
every position at running back at
receiver a quarterback at defensive line
even their offensive linemen are
athletic and and so they are the fastest
team in the league and they when any any
one of those guys has the ball in their
hand they can score and and make
something happen it's uh kind of fun to
watch no I know but that's how they put
it together but it is Andy just like a
different guy I mean what are you well
you're awesome Wade right he looks good
look he's gonna get a cover of GQ I got
a feeling here bright but if you have an
epiphany like the way he we used to do
it wasn't working anymore so just like
just become a doing it you know what
he's doing it the same way he's always
done it rich I mean he had he does the
same in terms of practice routine during
the week and same game plan I I think
he's tweaked is his offense you know
he's one of the West Coast offense guys
at tweaks and you know he's got that
that whole jet sweet package that
they're having a blast with and and I
think a lot of teams in the league are
doing some of that it came from college
and and so he's got the players to do it
Tyree kill is is crazy fast and III felt
bad for me I remember doing a preseason
game and Spencer where got hurt and I
went oh my god Andy there goes he was
their leading everything last year and
then this you know who would have thunk
that this Kareem hunt kid was going to
be as good as he is nobody I don't even
think they knew that
yeah sorry Steve Mariucci Anna penny
morning here on the Rich Eisen show
they're just having a ball and he's
trying to be creative with the try to
spread the ball around with all those
weapons and in Travis Kelce there's a
heck of a tight end to is as good as
there is in the league and so and Alex
Smith is an MVP guy and I'm so happy
well believe me up here in San Francisco
believe me people are saying I wish we
said he used to be my neighbor he used
to be right over here
and and in Elizabeth I lived here with
their kids and and they was really loved
up here okay cuz he's that great guy and
they're saying what if we still had Alex
Smith when they get rid of him and go to
my home's we get Alex back it's like oh
my god I mean this this guy's uh he's
really he's really doing well for
himself he is and and he deserves he's
one of those good guys as you point out
there I do want to ask you about the
play calling at the end of the Cowboys
Packers game by Dallas and walk me
through what is it like having a headset
on calling plays knowing that you're
running a five-minute offense with eight
minutes to go and you're pulling it off
do you panic saying you need to score at
the end because the Cowboys did not
finish that off with the amount of time
still left on the clock Aaron Rodgers to
not do what he eventually did Steve what
is it like Colin place in that situation
we call it a four-minute offense okay
actually yeah they needed to take the
lead it's really not a format they were
they're trying to they're trying to
score a touchdown that was the ultimate
goal they needed to score okay they
needed to score a touchdown in so doing
they wanted to chew clock so they tried
to be methodical and then that drive
where was it a 17 play drive rich 17
play yeah it's totally on the ground
right and it was the right show that
it's gonna be good no I know that's deep
but it's obvious that they're that their
goal was to take all of the remaining
time off the clock and yet they seem to
just flush that down the toilet
when they're trying to go up top to end
the drive on second and one with a
minute and gemsto the call I knew you're
going to refer to that one because see
so you call plays to accomplish those
goals we need to end up in the end zone
but we need to choose some clock and and
you know what they did it was a it was a
masterful job now they get down there
and they throw everybody in the stadium
probably figures and then as a play
caller you go alright what what will
work
what will fool them what can score you
know that kind of thing
and they felt that the Packers you know
felt well maybe they're going to just
keep running the ball like the air so
they called a little play-action pass
for the touchdown for that dagger and
you know what it had a chance but it was
incomplete stop the clock
that's 40 seconds for Aaron Rodgers that
was like a 40 second birthday present
for Aaron Rodgers but they end up
scoring they end up scoring in it's like
oh my god here we go again and with a
minute and 13 Aaron Rodgers just does
his magic just like he didn't in the
divisional playoff game last year it was
a heck of a game best game of the season
I thought ask Steve the poll question
Christopher go for it on our app on our
app which if you don't have Apple App
Store Google Play at the link at the top
of our Twitter handle and read jaws and
show Chris mooch who's the best team in
the NFC Eagles NFC eagles falcons
Packers Panthers Seahawks I hate the to
my own horn rich but we had this
discussion on game day morning all right
who's the best team in the NFC right and
we've had across the desk the panel we
had people say the Lions and what is
Curt say I remember I don't listen What
did he say I think he said the lines to
Steve I think they didn't say that what
a mooch say whatever [ __ ] you said the
Packers hackers and I said because of
their roster and Kurt gave me grief well
isn't the rosters at the T I mean
because I said when they get healthy and
they're still not healthy my daniels our
best defensive lineman didn't play david
Bakhtiari who happens to be from Tom
Brady's high school right up the street
here he didn't play their left tackle
they got Bulaga back finally but but
they're not they're not completely
healthy at time Montgomery didn't play
and I said the Packers are when they're
healthy but just maybe the Packers are
even before they're healthy Kurt said
the Falcons Kurt said the Falcons right
and and the Falcons have beaten before
the pack
twice and the Packers have won all the
other 12 games in losing twice for the
Falcons and they've beaten everybody
else but both of those Falcon games were
down in Atlanta so so I think they're on
a collision course well don't count out
Dallas because they're pretty darn good
too
I don't know man they just don't seem to
have that same fire in their belly like
they did the last couple of years the
lines definitely not as good without
Doug free and I am genuinely concerned
that they're just not closing games out
and it's gonna keep piling up and Carson
Wentz is gonna win that division based
on what I see because I can't wait to
see Carson Wentz again scam both four
and one teams on Thursday Night Football
it's going to be awesome you're right
the Eagles are a very good team too but
I'm not kidding don't count out the
Cowboys man that offense about you
mentioned Doug free and yes they miss
him but they move Lyle Collins over
there to the right tackle he's going to
be overall he's gonna be better than
Doug free this kid's gonna be a Pro
Bowler it's just a matter of you know
getting used to play in that position
sure and you know they're they're gonna
be good Dallas is going to be right
there with with the Eagles before before
let you go already before I let you go
Steve why a tittle passed away about 10
minutes ago at the age of 90 I know you
have some thoughts on the passing of one
of the best quarterbacks of his
generation
yeah I got to know why he tittle and his
son up here they you know they they
settled in the San Jose area he was a
49er icon went to the Giants New York
Giants football Giants and we all
remember that iconic picture of him
right on the field kneeling with blood
coming down his face and and and that's
why he's a tough guy he's a tough guy
and he and he was dropped to by the
Niners played here 10 years and then of
course they replaced him with John Brody
but that's when he went to the Giants
and really really also made a name for
himself there but he passed away today
so keep the great hall of famer giant
and 49er in your prayers today in his
family great man got to know them and
just uh just one of those guys from the
good old days that we're gonna miss much
love you see on Thursday was Thursday
yeah you got it
to make that trip across the world I'll
see in our way yeah well we'll be doing
it from Los Angeles the Eagles in the
the Panthers the pre-post and halftime
on NFL Network that Steve Mariucci
Monday's with mooch at Steve Mariucci
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience isn't it amazing
you can download an app with your
thumbprint you should download our app
with your thumbprint